في حين أنه كان من دواعي سرور الله القدير
أن يدعو
رحمته السيدة الراحلة ذات السيادة
الملكة إليزابيث الثانية
ذات الذكرى المباركة
والمجيدة التي من خلال وفاتها
جاء تاج المملكة المتحدة
لبريطانيا العظمى وأيرلندا الشمالية
إلى الأمير تشارلز فيليب آرثر
جورج
نحن  لذلك
فإن الرب الروحي والمعبد لهذا
العالم
وأعضاء بيت المشاعات
مع أعضاء آخرين من
المجلس الملكي لجلالة الملك الراحل
وممثلي
الممالك والأقاليم أعضاء مجلس الإدارة ومواطني لندن
وغيرهم
يفعلون الآن
بصوت واحد وموافقة اللسان  والقلب
ينشران ويعلنان أن الأمير تشارلز فيليب آرثر
جورج قد أصبح الآن
بوفاة ملكنا الراحل
ذاكرتنا السعيدة ،
أصبح
اللورد تشارلز الثالث الشرعي والشرعي الوحيد
بفضل الله في المملكة المتحدة
لبريطانيا العظمى وأيرلندا الشمالية
و  من عوالمه وأقاليمه الأخرى
ملك
رئيس الكومنولث
المدافع عن
الإيمان لمن  om لقد أخذنا العلم
بكل إيمان وطاعة بعاطفة متواضعة
نطلب من
الله الذي يحكم الملوك والملكات
أن يبارك جلالته
بسنوات طويلة وسعيدة ليحكمنا
نظرًا لأنه في قصر جيمس في
اليوم العاشر من سبتمبر
في عام سيدنا
حفظ الله الملك
ثلاث
هتافات لجلالة الملك الهيب
الصيحة
الورك الورك
[تصفيق]